hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my flash episode 15 video so awesome
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen it yet we have to talk about the
end WTF we have to talk about all this
king shark stuff so let's get going
there is a new round of the giveaway now
because there's a shortage of
reverse-flash rings it's just gonna be a
normal giveaway $20 Amazon gift card all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so big stuff first I know
everyone's really confused about that
twist at the end with Jay Garrick does
that mean that Jay Garrick is zoom kind
of yes technically no I've read a couple
interviews with the producers most of
them do a really poor job of
distinguishing between which version of
Jay Garrick you're talking about is it
earth 1 hunter zolomon is it earth 2 Jay
Garrick is it some variation of earth to
Jay Garrick none of them explain who the
man in the iron mask is even though I
think that is Jay Garrick a version of
Jay Garrick so that means we have three
jay garrick's because zoom ripping the
mask off that's Jay Garrick underneath
there the body that he dumped is a
different version of Jay Garrick that he
ripped through the portal at the end of
last week's episode and then the man in
the iron mask is another version of Jay
Garrick and I think the answer to all
this WTF is the velocity-9 formula
technically it be the velocity-6 formula
because team flash took it to velocity 9
Jay Garrick was the one that took it to
velocity 6 we're gonna have to be really
careful about which version we're
talking about this version of Jay
Garrick told Caitlin that there were
weird things that happen when he took
the formula he's afraid doesn't want
Barry to do it I think the formula is
what led to the creation of zoom because
this version of Jay Garrick has yellow
lightning like Barry this version of Jay
Garrick that is zoom has blue lightning
but what does this have to do with
unders olam on so I'm gonna go ahead and
do top 10 WTF and I'll talk about the
difference between hunter zolomon and
what I think was going on when Jay
Garrick showed hunter zolomon to Caitlin
I think there was a lot of trickery
involved and even though this version of
Jay Garrick the one that seems like he's
dead now was good I think that he was
still misleading team flash especially
based on some of the interviews I've
been reading so number 10 WTF Harrison
wells tells Barry and Cisco not to tell
anyone about earth 2 so the minute you
tell someone not to tell a secret to
someone else that's the guarantee that
they will tell them eventually
so everyone ends up finding out about
earth 2 for most of the episode it's a
bad thing until you get to the Cisco
reveal when Caitlin just works it out of
them then they use it for comedy but yes
the bay
reveal to Iris about them being married
about Joe dying that's gonna come back
in the future but I don't think that
Barry and iris are gonna get together
anytime soon there's just way too much
craziness going on right now but it will
be addressed in the future number 9 WTF
earth to King shark still alive
in an Argus prison so LYLAS in charge
team Diggle comes over to the flash it's
so awesome to see them and it's
interesting to know that Amanda Waller
was trying to weaponize metahumans that
sounds like something Amanda Waller
would do Task Force X was already a
thing but it sounds like she was just
trying to use metahumans to make a super
version The Suicide Squad comic book
version of Task Force X and he is
freaking huge king shark looks amazing
they definitely upgraded his CG since
the last time we saw him and they
addressed the fact that he was supposed
to have died after episode 4 that's what
that conversation with Joe was all about
with Barry cuz I thought that Harrison
wells killed him well I guess not I
guess they put him in Argus prison
speaking of prison number eight WTF
Barry on game night I guess I'm the
fastest one I'm the champ you see how
competitive Wally is with Barry I like
the way they kind of work through their
in this episode but by no means is
it over it's gonna take some time some
Speed Force accidents for them to come
together you really see it on Barry's
face here they did a good job of
telegraphing how this was gonna be a big
thing this week where Diggle is like
dude you got that Oliver look on your
face the weight of the world on my
shoulders
that shit'll slow you down and if the
flash TV show does anything really well
I think they leave the emotional story
of the characters in with like the
actual plot story like this this fight
with king shark about how Barry is
slowed down because he's weighed down by
the weight of the world
number seven WTF Harrison wells is being
kind of a dick to Jesse quick although
they do get past it really quick they
had that awesome dad daughter moment
where it's like hey I'm here let me help
seriously come on dad true to name she'd
probably just as smart if not smarter
than her father and she's wearing one of
the STAR Labs shirts so she's officially
team flash now which is just awesome
number six WTF Cisco versus the memory
of killer frost there were so many puns
in this episode any time Cisco had a
scene with Caitlin he was making killer
frost puns she's been so cold her icy
touch anytime wally was with Barry
there's always Speed puns I like the way
they do that this could be the beginning
of her turning evil Cisco I'll never
turn evil that was actually the moment I
turned my head I was like oh wait she
said the worst thing she could have
possibly said anytime you say
something will never happen it almost
guarantees that it will happen at some
point it's like you're breaking the rule
of a horror movie
number five WTF catching up with team
arrow Cisco asks Diggle about his helmet
how's that working out for you
and that's a good man needs some work ok
I'll make it better Cisco going to be
making some new tech for diggle's helmet
that's cool in Barry asks about felicity
remember she's been in the wheelchair
they haven't really addressed it she
hasn't been answering my phone calls his
ok man I got it I'll tell him to give
you a call back
so they did a pretty good job of
addressing that this week there's always
the question when big WTF stuff happens
on each show why they don't address it
on the other show all of her son is a
really good example that if something
crazy happens with him this week then
they'll probably address it in some
future episode of the flash with the
line of dialogue like they did this week
with felicity number 4 WTF Barry versus
Wally if it wasn't awkward before they
completely jumped the shark when Barry
tries to help with his engine I love the
setup because it means that he'll be
able to contribute and work with Cisco
who is the engineer of STAR Labs you
have a crazy idea for something Cisco's
the one that builds it if Wally becomes
an engineer that means that he'll be
able to contribute so they're just
laying groundwork for that to happen in
the future now while he's trying to get
into college right now so it's just the
beginning so it might not happen for a
while but when he does meet Cisco
he and while you're gonna have a really
awesome time playing with cars number
three WTF this is so much fun
King shark rips the roof off of Joe's
house I don't suppose my insurance cover
sharknado attacks
Wally's line was even better how come
you guys aren't more freaked out by a
shark wearing pants it did kind of suck
when Wally called Barry a coward I don't
know how long it's gonna be before Wally
finds out that Barry's the flash and I
am hoping by the end of the season Wally
is team flash even if he doesn't have
powers but he can't do that until he
learns Barry is the flash like usually
you find out that he's the flash and you
gain access to the inner circle number
two WTF Barry versus King shark in the
water
total Jaws style more fishing with bait
puns more jaws lines I wanted to be
Quint you know quick died in that movie
Cisco so Barry uses his tornado ability
or technically it'd be a hurricane
because it's in water to shock king
sharks so it's like shock NATO give me
all your lightning sharknado jokes this
is so great and the visual effects are
great I love the way they beefed up King
shark he seemed even bigger than he did
the last time we saw
but if there's any confusion he is back
in the hands of Argos now Lila is gonna
try and help him but because he's such
an awesome character there's no way he's
gonna go away for forever so they'll
totally bring him back whenever they can
but now we got to talk about the number
one WTF Jay Garrick zoom reveal at the
end what the hell is going on what's up
with hunters olam on and which version
of Jay Garrick was masterminding all
this the whole time so what I think
might be going on is that the man in the
mask is earth-1 Jay Garrick in the Jay
Garrick that we've known this whole time
has actually been a twin of zoom from
earth-2 they're both rumored to zoom and
Jay Garrick they are separate entities
but here's the real question and I think
it has something to do with the
velocity-9 formula Jay Garrick got the
Speed Force during the particle
accelerator explosion experimented with
the formula to make himself faster I
think the physical manifestation of zoom
is a side effect of that formula so the
Jay Garrick that we've known probably
knows that zoom exists and is a version
of him and has just been keeping that
from everyone so he's been misleading
everyone but he is a good person
zoom is an evil person they just like
the split aspect of Jay Garrick now he
could also be you know alternate theory
he could also be a cobalt blue type
character as in an actual physical twin
before the particle accelerator
explosion but I think the idea is is
that the velocity-9 formula twisted the
original Jay Garrick to create zoom so
that you have two copies running around
one evil one good and as we know the
good version of Jay Garrick was
degenerating like his cells were
breaking down he says it's a side effect
of the velocity-6 formula that formula
in the creation of zoom like the aspect
of Jay Garrick the zoom creation is
probably the reason why zoom needs to
take speedforce from Barry like he can't
just generate it like Barry does if you
ever watch Buffy the Vampire Slayer or
Angel you have the angel character and
you have the Angelus character but it's
the same person angel is the version of
Angelus the vampire with the soul when
he loses the soul he becomes Angelus
imagine that same character being split
into two so they have a version of the
character that's angel with the soul and
you have a separate entity that is
Angelus that's what I think is going on
with earth to Jay Garrick so when Jay
Garrick was telling Caitlin about hunter
zolomon I think that he was pointing to
zoom the actual zoom in
for this happened when Kaitlyn could not
find jay garrick from earth one they had
stolen that jay garrick and put him in
the iron mask it's the only thing the
producers have said to support this is
that Jay Garrick was deceiving team
flash the whole time our good Jay
Garrick not the zoom character remember
Jay Garrick and zoom are two completely
different characters but they're both
versions of Jay Garrick now I know
you're all freaking out the producers
did say that they would explain what's
going on with this complication in the
man in the iron mask over the next
couple of weeks so they're not gonna
wait for forever to explain it so let me
know in the comments who is the man in
the iron mask
who is this version of Jay Garrick and
who is the Zoom version of Jay Garrick
like I said I think it's an angel
Angelus getting split into situation for
the earth 2 version of Jay Garrick I
think this is earth 1 Jay Garrick and I
think in the broader context it's kind
of explaining the different aspects of
the Speed Force like the negative and
the positive aspects of the Speed Force
very positive Speed Force zoom professor
zoom in the comics at least negative
Speed Force but what's gonna happen is
is tomorrow is another big night for
arrow vixen is debuting from the comics
it's gonna be so much fun and Thursday
legends of tomorrow is doing Jericho I
think or maybe Grant Wilson it might be
ravager depending on how they explained
it I think it's gonna be Slade Wilson's
son and Connor Hawke so it's just gonna
be a whole badass week for TV while you
guys continue to freak out about all
this stuff you can click here for my
Civil War spider-man video that I just
posted and you can click here for my
Batman V Superman Justice League teaser
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight